le vélo en hiver et joies du vélo en
hiver pour certains c'est séduit de plus
en plus de montréal et de cyclistes
montréalais alors et bien évidemment on
revoit donc ses seins on les voit
souvent donc est ce toujours assez
impressionnant et on les félicite on
leur lève mon chapeau
voyons maintenant un portrait du vélo à
montréal montréal qui est bien cotée
comme on le voit sur cette prochaine
carte qui est inspiré d'un index qui se
fait à toutes les années un classement
qui est effectué par une firme danoise
avec des critères très très sérieux en
classe les villes pour si on veut
souligner l'effort déployé par les
autorités publiques pour faire la
promotion du vélo en général et montréal
dans tout ce dans tout ce palmarès là et
au 11e rang quand même c'est la première
donc en amérique du nord
les autres villes sont essentiellement
en europe y en a deux en asie au japon
mais montréal est donc devant paris
devant barcelone devant hambourg ce qui
est quand même pas mal amsterdam et
copenhague sont les deux premières
villes au monde
voilà pour ce palmarès poursuivant juste
avant que montréal les voies cyclables
on voit ici les voies cyclables à
montréal en ce moment c'est 600
kilomètres mais à cela s'ajoute le bixi
depuis 2009 qui rend c'est intéressant
toronto ses passes en 12 mai 400 plutôt
faudra corriger et 400 cd chef de donc
2011 620 km pour vancouver 320 km pour
ottawa revoilà donc en terme de
kilométrage en ce qui concerne les voies
cyclables et on voit poursuivre
maintenant avec ce réseau blanc se sont
toutes les pistes cyclables à montréal
d'énergie durant l'hiver et on n'en
doutais que sur la piste ici de
maisonneuve est celle de rached de 12 à
14% des cyclistes continue à faire du
vélo en hiver et rêvons pour terminer
cette photo c'est un projet d'un
architecte londonien imaginez peut-être
un jour morale qui sait des voies
cyclables donc suspendu dans les airs au
dessus des trains de banlieue 220 km
c'est un projet qui a le soutien des
autorités en matière de transport à
londres alors on verra si ça fera école
un peu partout dans le monde